[Music]
[Applause]
i'm chris voss and over the next 30 days
you will learn key negotiation skills
you can use to become a more confident
colleague trusted leader and advance
your professional life
you're going to practice and use 12
proven negotiation tactics that i
developed as an fbi negotiator
the upward inflection helps harsh things
land gently when you mirror it starts to
help you focus more on the other person
if you're curious if you're actually
curious it's going to come out in your
voice how am i supposed to continue
working for you
if i'm not getting paid
as you progress the tools will build on
each other first you will learn how to
build trust and rapport at work then you
will learn how to strengthen your
influence with calibrated questioning
techniques finally you will learn how to
create epiphanies in order to get to the
agreement or to get the agreement to
come to you
during our time together there will be
interactive practice scenarios with a
community of other fellow negotiators
collaboration between colleagues that's
really a negotiation
and when your intent is to collaborate
with people for a better result
then it's always appropriate to
negotiate
i'm chris voss and this
is masterclass
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you